the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we're now on story board 12 session 13
let's take a look first at panel a I
mentioned earlier that respiration is
the oxidative metabolism of all
metabolic fuels carbohydrates as well as
lipids if we were starting with a
carbohydrate than respiration starts
with the pyruvate dehydrogenase reaction
and then proceeds into the TCA cycle and
then into electron transport and
oxidative phosphorylation
if the acetyl co a comes from fatty acid
oxidation which we'll cover later that
we do not have to do the pyruvate
dehydrogenase step three molecules of
NADH and one molecule of fadh2 are
produced as the carriers of electrons
from the intermediates in the TCA cycle
from each input molecule of acetyl
coenzyme a as I mentioned a number of
times we look at nadh and fadh2 is
relatively mobile electron carriers
they're going to be picking up electrons
from intermediates and biochemical
pathways and then they bring those
electrons into the mitochondrial inner
membrane where the reducing equivalents
are passed along to the electron
transport chain ultimately the electrons
will end up being deposited into oxygen
to make water let's turn to panel B
where I'm going to start laying out the
big picture in this small cartoon we see
fuel being oxidized to carbon dioxide
the electrons are passed to either nad
plus or fa d to form the reduced
cofactor the reduced cofactors find
their way to the mitochondrial inner
membrane and the electrons are reducing
equivalents are passed to oxygen to make
water this process is highly exergonic
and we'll do a model calculation in a
minute to show just how energy-yielding
it is resulting in the liberation of a
lot of free energy that energy is
captured by the movement of protons
from one side of the mitochondrial inner
membrane to the other side of the
membrane in this process you're taking a
low concentration of protons and
creating a relatively high concentration
of protons that's an uphill process
that's going to require an energy input
and the energy from nutrient oxidation
is what powers this generation of an ion
gradient concentrating the protons in a
small defined space is kind of like
charging a battery it took energy to
create that high concentration of
protons we'll see that nature invented a
way to channel the protons back through
a device and a way to capture the energy
released when the gradient is dissipated
that energy can be captured in various
ways enabling us to be able to do useful
things with it for example the energy
could be used to accomplish the
otherwise energy requiring process of
putting a phosphate onto ADP to make ATP
and that way the energy is captured in a
chemical bond alternatively let's think
of a situation in which you may need to
generate heat you could allow the proton
simply to flow back across the membrane
through a channel the energy of the
proton gradient would then be released
as heat thirdly we can perhaps allow the
protons to flow back through a device
that creates rotary movement and that's
how for example a flagellar motor can
spin to move a bacterium from one place
to another let's now turn to panel C
we've seen earlier that oxidation can
result in the production of nadh or
fadh2 to begin let's consider NADH in
this panel you can see the NADH oxidized
where the electrons flow and it doesn't
matter what the path of the flow is all
the way to oxygen thermodynamics gives
us the tools to calculate how much
energy you would get in this process
Joanne taught you a lot about
thermodynamics and biological systems
and this is just a repeat of what she
said but what I'm going to do is put
what she said into a concrete practical
example I've drawn out at the bottom of
panels see the overall reaction showing
electrons going from NADH to oxygen in
the four
word direction now of course we could
also think about the back reaction where
electrons would flow from water in to
NAD+ to form NADH at this point this is
just an equation on a piece of paper and
we don't know in which direction the
reaction is overall favorable that is is
it favorable in the forward direction as
drawn left to right or in the reverse
direction right to left the reaction
from left to right is the direction we
usually think about in the context of
nutrient oxidation interestingly the
reaction from right to left is
photosynthesis so both directions are
biologically used but we'll see that one
of the directions will require
substantial energy input in order to
make it biologically useful probably you
can appreciate that photosynthesis is
the energy requiring process because we
all know that sunlight is needed to make
the process thermodynamically and
kinetically favorable we don't cover
photosynthesis in 507 so let me say a
few words about it in photosynthesis
nature takes electrons from water and
uses them to reduce nadp+ to nadph note
that I said in adp plus and not any d
plus but for the purposes here they are
equivalent in the case of photosynthesis
we know intuitively that the overall
process is power bud light so in going
from right to left the process
intuitively once again should require
energy
by contrast nutrient oxidation where we
go from left to right in this equation
should be a process that generates
energy but intuition aside let's do the
calculation so the question is in which
direction is the equation at the bottom
of paneled seat thermodynamically
favorable left to right or right to left
let's take a look now at panel D you'll
see here that I have split the master
equation into two half reactions
I always write out the half reaction in
the direction of reduction for example
look at the second half reaction it
shows that half a mole of oxygen plus
two protons plus two electrons go to
water again I've written out these
reactions in the direction of reduction
it's just the way I do it
next I go to the redox chart that is a
table of redox potentials of
electrochemical reactions and I figure
out what the standard energies are for
each of these half reactions as you can
see it's 0.32 volts and plus point eight
two volts respectively for the two half
reactions next I use variant of the
Nernst equation to calculate the free
energy and ultimately the directionality
of the reaction the equation I use is
Delta G naught prime equals n times
Faraday's constant times the difference
in the reduction potentials of the two
half-reactions
to find Delta e naught Prime we look at
the reaction that I've written out the
overall reaction and we look to see
which is the electron acceptor and which
is the electron donor the way the
reaction was written then we subtract
the reduction potential of the electron
receptor from that of the electron donor
the way the equation is written left to
right oxygen is the electron acceptor
its reduction potential is plus 0.8 2
volts so Delta e naught prime is plus
0.8 to minus a minus 0.32 or a total of
plus 1 point 1 4 volts in the Nernst
equation the number of electron
transferred in this case is 2 in
Faraday's constant is 96.4 kilojoules
per mole times volts if you do the math
or as we say at MIT plug and chug what
you find out is that the free energy
change of the reaction that's written
the NADH oxidation reaction is minus 220
kilojoules per mole this number is
negative and that means the reaction is
favorable as drawn that is the reaction
goes from left to right the 220
kilojoules is the amount of energy
that's available for the three purposes
of the pathway that is ATP synthesis
heat generation or movement if we were
going to make ATP we would divide 220 by
32 because we get about 30
kilojoules of energy by hydrolysis of
ATP and we can calculate that we're
going to get something in the order of
about three atps for every NADH that
gives up two electrons to the electron
transport chain we could easily do the
same oxidation reaction and study fadh2
but in this case we would calculate that
we would get actually less energy
because the oxidation potential of
Flavin's as compared to nad is different
in that case that is fadh2 oxidation
will get only about two atps per fadh2
oxidize so the fadh2 produced in the
succinate dehydrogenase step of the TCA
cycle is less energy yielding man
for example the oxidation of malate to
oxaloacetate that occurs later in the
pathway let's turn now to storyboard
thirteen we now have an idea of the
rough amount of energy that's going to
be generated by nutrient oxidation next
we're going to look a little bit more in
detail at the mechanism by which the
electrons are transported from the
reduced substances that constitute our
electron donors nadh and fadh2 to
molecular oxygen or whatever the
terminal electron acceptor is in the
biological system under study as we've
seen the electron transfer process that
we've been studying liberate energy and
that energy is going to be used to power
pumps that will transport protons from
the matrix of the mitochondrion out into
the intermembrane space between the
mitochondrial inner and outer membranes
in the case of electron transport with
the goal of ATP synthesis the protons
that are generated in the intermembrane
space will be allowed to flow back
through a device that mechanically
couples motion that is the spinning of a
shaft to drive conformational changes in
enzymes that will allow the otherwise
endergonic synthesis of ATP from ADP and
inorganic phosphate that machine is
called the ATP synthase let's look at
panel a this panel shows the details of
the electron transport system it looks a
little bit complicated but let's not
lose sight of the fact
what it's all about is powering pumps
pumps that pump protons in the lower
left of the panel we see the TCA cycle
generating nadh and fadh2 the nadh
approaches complex one of the
mitochondrial inner membrane complex one
is an NADH dehydrogenase enzyme the
enzyme has a flavin that accepts the
electrons from NADH passes them along to
iron sulfur centers and then to a
variety of cytochromes and moves the
electrons up to the point where they're
going to be transferred to coenzyme q in
its oxidized form coenzyme q binds to
complex one the oxidized form of
coenzyme q will be reduced first to a
semi CRO known and then to a
hydroquinone which are located as shown
inside the mitochondrial inner membrane
we usually draw them as being
free-floating within the membrane but
that's probably inaccurate these
cofactors are probably bound to physical
entities inside the mitochondrial inner
membrane the picture also shows fadh2
from the TCA cycle interacting with
complex 2 which is a flavin containing
enzyme and it will also transfer its
electrons to the oxidized form of
coenzyme q ultimately to create the
reduced coenzyme q h 2 which is the
hydroquinone just as a point of
reference to the TCA cycle complex 2 is
also known as succinate dehydrogenase we
haven't done fatty acid oxidation yet
but there's a step in fatty acid
oxidation in which an alkane is
converted to an alkene the electrons
from that oxidation reaction go through
a flavin protein called ETF pre for
electron transferring flavor protein and
once again those electrons flow into
coenzyme q to form the reduced form of
coenzyme q remember when we talked about
the glycerol 3-phosphate shuttle i
mentioned that there's a mitochondrial
membrane associated glycerol 3-phosphate
dehydrogenase you can see that enzyme at
the top part of the inner membrane as
i've drawn it and once again flavin in
that enzyme will carry the electrons
into coenzyme q generating
reduced form of the cofactor qh2 the
left part of this picture pretty neatly
shows how nutrient oxidation can channel
the electrons into a common mobile
electron carrier coenzyme q lots of
different fuels give up their electrons
to a common electron carrier the
hydroquinone q h2 will then go and
interact with complex three of the
electron transport chain in complex
three electrons will be transported
through a number of different electron
relay stations and ultimately be picked
up by cytochrome c which is in initially
in its +3 oxidation state cytochrome c
is reduced by the single electron coming
through complex 3 in this process its
iron is reduced to its +2 state this
electron on cytochrome c then migrates
across the outer surface of the inner
membrane of the mitochondrion to
interact with complex 4 when it
interacts with complex for the reduced
form of cytochrome c gives up its
electron to a copper residue on the
copper a subunit of complex 4 in the
figure this complex is called Cu a the
more common name for a complex four is
cytochrome C oxidase so cytochrome C
oxidase oxidizes the iron back to its
iron 3 oxidation state then cytochrome C
migrates back to complex 3 where it's
able to pick up another electron we can
think of cytochrome C as a mobile
electron carrier that shuttles an
electron along the inner surface of the
mitochondrial inner membrane looking
back at complex 4 or cytochrome C
oxidase the electrons are passed from
cytochrome a to a series of other
electron carriers and ultimately they
flow into molecular oxygen molecular
oxygen is anchored on one side to heme
a3 and on the other side to copper B
oxygen undergoes a 4 electron reduction
and picks up 4 protons along the way to
form 2 molecules of water if the
electron started with NADH and ends up
in oxygen to form water
you get 220 kilojoules of energy and as
I said you get somewhat less if your
electron started out as a reduced flavin
now let's look at panel B I want to say
a few words at the outset about proton
pumps keeping in mind that the reason
electrons were moved through the
electron transport chain was to power
these pumps in the lower-left part of
the figure we can see complex one the
transit of electrons through complex one
from nadh results in the transport of
four protons from the mitochondrial
matrix into the intermembrane space that
is two electrons from NADH are
transported and coincident with that
four protons are pumped into the
intermembrane space later we'll see that
complex 3 is location of something
called the Q cycle I'm going to cover
the proton pumping properties of the q
sy q cycle in some detail in the next
storyboard the passage of those two
electrons through complex three results
in the transport of an additional four
protons into the intermembrane space
lastly the transit of electrons through
complex for the cytochrome C oxidase
results in the transport of another two
protons into the intermembrane space now
let's look at panel C adding things up
if we start with two electrons coming
from NADH we transport about 10 protons
into the intermembrane space that's
enough to make about three molecules of
ATP if our electrons start with fadh2
reduced flavin we only transport about
six protons that's enough to make two
ATP's if you remember making ATP is only
one of the things that we can do with
the power of the proton gradient I
mentioned earlier that we can also use
it to generate heat and motion let me
talk for a minute about why one would
want to generate heat newborn babies are
like small balls they have a high
surface to volume ratio their high
surface to volume ratio makes heat loss
a very significant reality and in fact a
problem for the newborn they have
therefore specialised mitochondria in
their neck in an area called brown fat
the fat is brown because
loaded with highly colored mitochondria
these mitochondria have a protein that
enables the protons pumped into the
intermembrane space to flow back freely
into the mitochondrial matrix with the
generation of heat that is they don't
make ATP in the brown fat they make heat
this helps promote thermal regulation in
the baby this is also the mechanism by
which hibernating animals such as a bear
can maintain body temperature during the
winter when the bear is hibernating this
process overall is called uncoupling of
electron transport from the process that
we're going to be looking at next
oxidative phosphorylation oxidative
phosphorylation is the process by which
we're going to be making ATP uncoupling
is also a process used by some flowers
that have to come up through frozen
ground in the springtime for example the
skunk cabbage and the crocus are very
good at uncoupling electron transport
from oxidative phosphorylation
they let the protons in the proton
gradient flow back across the
mitochondrial inner membrane and by
doing so these plants are able to
generate heat that will allow them to
grow at sub-freezing temperatures in
other words the plant itself becomes a
little heater at this point let me give
you a little bit of a preview of how we
use this proton gradient in order to
synthesize ATP as we've seen it took
energy in order to create a gradient in
which there are protons in the
intermembrane space and protons are
chemical entities so we've created a
chemical gradient but also we're putting
a very high positive charge density in
the small enclosed inter membrane space
so we've also created an electrochemical
gradient it is the release of those
gradients that empowers many of our
vital processes for a final comment
please see panel D Peter Mitchell
figured out how the energy in that
electrochemical gradient could be
released and converted into the energy
it takes to make chemical bonds
Mitchell's conclusions serve as the
basis of what is called the chemiosmotic
coupling hypothesis and we'd be looking
at that in some detail later